It was a short time, but thank you,
but I can't get everyone to work here
anymore.  I
thought there must be something, but it's
a bit too stimulating for you and the audience Hey, there's no
child-like shadow sitting there
Oh,
what are
you talking about?
Is it much, much, much better You know, there's
no such thing as a drowning volume's ferociousness
This time of Obon, souls return to wash their hearts in one of the
few sanctuaries
My father and I protect the souls of the dead  They're
like the guardians of this land,
but
yesterday you wielded a great deal of magical power that
warped the sanctuary, didn't
it?  I have to go
[music] I'm
sorry because that's what we're doing.
Regain what it should be, Aunt Mikiti is surely
waiting for a shift What is this
?